welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information on what antique
from your grandparents house that you
should bring with you to a fight hint
always grab the hurting gertie
my name is mt and i'm here today with
off-screen producer brandon what's going
on brother hello mt so happy to be here
today yeah grab that hurdy gertie it's a
very powerful instrument you can you can
win over the battle with the with a
sweet song or maybe just hit your
opponent in the head knock him out cold
boom
boom the amount of uh law and order
episodes that i've seen with uh death by
hurdy gertie is just too much
it's honestly just a overused trope at
this iced tea coming in man like he had
a herding gertie
look at me i just know stuff
you just try to buy it you have to buy a
hurdy gertie on the dark web
gotta buy it like this is a dangerous
weapon oh my god what's our big question
for today brandon well mt was so much
going on in the multiverse these days
it's hard to keep track of where some of
the most powerful devices are you know
leading up to infinity war we all knew
that the most powerful thing in the
universe were the infinity stones
plus that sweet sweet golden gauntlet
uh but now what you know now what what's
the big bad now what are we so scared of
you know as dr strange gets ready for
this big battle we want to know what
supreme artifacts he has at his disposal
you know what can he bring to this fight
that's going to give him the upper hand
and that leads us to this week's big
question what are the most powerful
artifacts still around in the mcu um
that's a great question brandon well the
mcu has introduced some really powerful
items during its amazing 14-year run and
while some of them may have been lost or
destroyed or even depowered there are
still a bunch of things out there that
could be very useful in a battle so
we're going to check in on some of the
most powerful artifacts out there in the
marvel cinematic universe and remind
ourselves where they are what they can
do and whether or not they might be
useful in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness let's dive in with
our first one the iphone 9 no one knows
what happened to that it never came out
still very useful still very useful
now this first one is sort of a gimme um
it's the dark hole from one division and
it's obviously going to play a huge part
in doctor strange 2 as we see it in the
trailer and currently ramana maximoff is
in possession of this dark magic tome
but we do know that doctor strange is
going to at least pull some red globs
out of it and then smash them back into
the book um because that's what you do
when you have the dark hole you just
play around with chaos energy why not
yeah smash it back in there now we don't
have a confirmed origin for the dark
hole in the mcu but in the comics it was
created by the elder god cathode and it
was his diary of darkness where he wrote
down all of his spells prophecies and
evil ruminations on indestructible pages
of flesh just like me that's how i write
my feelings uh i hate it twitter
knowledge and they make you go buy like
brand new books of flesh like every
semester and you're like can i just use
that that's why i use check the last
edition they're like no no no you gotta
buy the newest flesh books and you can't
even resell those flesh books now the
dark cold was featured on the marvel
show the runaways but that show is not
confirmed in the mcu cannon
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but it also looks completely different
on the runaways but it's possible that
the runaways version of the darkhold
could appear as a variant in the
multiverse of madness but that could be
really confusing so i don't really know
if marvel studios would want to do that
in particular yeah you're right that
they look different the mcu proper dark
code looks really cool the one they had
on runaways looked cool but it kind of
looked like if your high school was
doing a production of the multiverse of
madness and you know you had
your prop masters a junior in high
school and he had to make a book it it
didn't look super cool this one and the
mc looks very cool i like the way it
looks so we know that the dark cold is
going to be used in multiverse of
madness but how will it come into play
brandon what do you think yeah i you
know i'm sure that
doctor strange wants to get his hands on
this book right you know we know this
guy loves oh yeah because he loves
reading he reads so nerd he's reading in
his dreams he's doing all that stuff
he loves to break the rules all the time
you know he's go looking at books he's
not supposed to read pissing off wong
but i don't know if he knew of the
darkhold before
the events of war on division happen and
he hears about the black hole i don't i
don't know how up he was on the dark
hole if he had read about it in another
book or something but as soon as he
knows about it i'm sure he's like i got
to get this book right i got to see
what's in here i'm i'm the former
sorcerer supreme i'll be back long watch
your back but i want to read this book
and we know he gets his hands on it
right like you said he pulls out the red
gloves he smashes him back in but i
can't see a way that wanda gives this
book up easily because it's her book i
mean
it's basically it's got her picture in
it you know it's her book it's true it's
her book it has her name on it yeah i'm
worried that i'm worried that you know
dr strange stole the book and that's
really going to piss off wanda even more
and that's how it's going to come into
play i don't think the book is going to
respond well to doctor strange because
he doesn't mess around with dark magic
that much that we know of not not our
the what if strangers did yeah i think
it's gonna be a situation where he gets
the book he tries to use it and things
go awry as they often do for good old
doctor strange what about you mt no i
definitely think that you're you're
definitely on the money there i think
that doctor strange well especially like
this doctor strange variant defender
strange they're going to find uh the
darkholder interact with the darkhold
especially after the events of dr
strange one where you know casilius
almost destroyed the planet with dark
magic of some sort so these doctor
strange variants probably really want to
learn about chaos magic and the the
nature of dark right in general so like
i always say that doctor strange the
doctor strange series is just mcu
curious george that's exactly what it is
he's just too curious and he's just like
you know what i have to know so he's
gonna read that book he's gonna become
corrupted like agatha and probably wanda
at the end of one division yeah though
it's gonna play a big role for sure yeah
as doctor strange has said the
multiverse is something we know about
which we know frighteningly little but i
imagine that the darkhold has a lot to
say about the multiverse you know when
wanda was looking at it those little
globes we think are those little red
balls they're different universes right
probably the same thing when doctor
strange is doing his little magic so
it's like this is the one thing where
you can learn about the multiverse but
it's also shrouded in dark magic so
that's the dangerous part of it right
you can learn about the multiverse but
you're gonna let something out that you
didn't want to and i'm glad you brought
up the runaways version of the dark hole
too because i think that would be
interesting if there's like another dark
hole that gets pulled in we have to
assume every universe has its own dark
hole and maybe they interact in some way
like link them all together something
like that that's really yeah i really
like that idea of like variants of the
dark hole just coming together and like
maybe the illuminati has like a dark
hole library it's like we just take this
from yeah various wanderers and doctor
strangers that act up this library this
library is all copies of eat pray love
from every different universe uh and
this one is all dark holds do not get
them mixed up very dangerous
very dangerous they will both kill you
don't mistake they will both end your
life one thing i did like about the
darkhold on runaways was that
people couldn't read it right some
people if they looked at the book it was
like blank but if you had the power if
you had the magic when you looked at the
book you could see the words in it like
i like that little caveat that that way
you're keeping like the real danger out
of super unprepared hands it would be
interesting to find out if our dark hold
works that way too you know we've only
ever seen agatha and wanda interact with
it both of them have the touch they have
the power
so they're able to read the book
but it would be cool if like someone
else picks it up like bruce banner picks
it up and he's like i don't i don't see
anything you get a little westworld
actually where he's like this doesn't
look like anything to me this doesn't
look like anything
doesn't look like anything to me remind
you of that uh dw meme i can't read like
i can't read this side
i forget how it goes that song can't
stop me because i can't read
yeah i think that like we have universes
of light which is like where all of like
the human beings and aliens live and but
then like between these universes of
light there's the dark space and like we
sort of see it at the beginning of the
loki finale where they have these two
black holes and i think that they're the
space between those black holes is the
dark realm where all the the evil
creatures and like
the darkness leaves i like that idea
that there's like the dimensions can
kind of exist in between universes
they're not totally like wrapped up
inside of the universe because it's a
different dimension they can be in that
little in-between space you know it's
like the the idea that as you go down
right there's space in between
everything like even your tiny little
atoms there's ton your atoms in your
body are mostly empty space as you keep
going down you'll never find things
touching right there's always space
between everything no matter how small
you get in the quantum realm
you can't ever get things to touch so
it's like there's always that darkness
in between just touching me i'm not
touching you he's not touching me the
dark hold i think can be used as a way
to access that darkness or let stuff out
of that darkness like maybe that ribbon
monster we see in the trailer came out
of the darkhold because we don't know
everything this thing could do it's not
just a book of spells it has a lot of
power cathon put like so much darkness
into this thing you know they've used it
so much in the comics and in the comics
it's basically this endless resource of
stuff everything is in there they find
something new every day inside the dark
hole and even though it in the mcu no it
kind of looks like it's just like 10
pages right it looks it looks kind of
small like the pages look kind of thick
and weird but i bet it's one of those
weird magical things where you just keep
flipping and there's always new pages to
find like there's no end to it it's
probably like a magic tablet or
something of some sort where like each
page changes it's like what do you need
i'm a text of the darkest most arcane
type i could be of great assistance to
you
i i really do want to see more of the
dark golden like who else is in there
yeah like
who else is damned because it's not only
wanda that's the book
[Music]
a new item that we should certainly be
discussing are the ten rings which were
recently introduced in shanghai in the
legend of the ten rings i mean these
fashionable accessories pack a powerful
punch granting the wielder of these
rings enhanced strength and longevity
and wen was able to live for a thousand
years with these circle weapons on his
arms good god what a what a perk i would
love to live for a thousand years and uh
not die
but then again
i'll take like 300 years and that's
enough then i'm tired i need a nap yeah
you know 300 is good you know as long as
i can get to the next avengers movie
yeah um i'm good it's been 84 years and
the rings can be fired like projectiles
used as protective shields and channel
energy blasts which is super super dope
when woo like literally when was using
these rings in shanghai one of the
coolest things of the mcu that i've ever
seen like i'm very sad that he's dead
because like yeah my god he knew how to
use those rings yeah real good i like
when shang chi like put him on his foot
and we're like now i'm going to kick you
really hard and i was like oh that's
smart that was smart i gotta just punch
put him on your foot
hit him i'd like to see like him like
you know when he first gets the ring
he's like how many different ways can i
use this i would put this on my foot
don't don't think too hard about that
question you gotta get a pretty
but yeah in the post-credits scene of
chongqi we see wang examining the rings
along with holograms of bruce and carol
danvers what we don't know is if wang
kept the rings or he or let chiang chi
hang on to them and wang does mention
that they're not listed in any of kamar
taj's codexes so i guess that he doesn't
have any eldritch magic claim over any
of the rings so you know it would make
sense for him to just let she keep them
yeah we're not sure what they're made of
exactly or if they're even of
extraterrestrial origin but bruce banner
does confirm that they are much older
than 1000 years and the rings do seem to
operate on some sort of magic because
when shengshi started to use them with
the talo magic wang does mention that he
felt the use of the rings like he felt
while shang chi using the rings while he
was in tallow and presumably he never
felt them before when when wu was
utilizing them so what do we think could
the 10 rings be utilized in the
multiverse of madness brandon i i would
love to see him come back again i don't
want to wait until you know shang qi2 to
see these rings again they were so
awesome and we got to see them really
used in like you know the last third of
that movie but there was so much of that
movie we're not seeing them in action i
want to see sean chi like having the
whole time right but i i think that wong
let shang chi keep the rings you know
you mentioned he was like oh they're not
in any of our codexes so we couldn't
pull like a british museum and be like
these are ours now mine come and get
them killmonger we're taking these from
you oh these are magic items uh you you
can't have these these are ours they
belong to magic people he could have
tried to pull that move but he didn't
pull it so i i think that chongqi does
still have them and i think yeah you
like you said you have to have some sort
of magic to use them but it was
interesting that wong never sensed it
you know they were never sensing it when
when woo was using them you know when he
used it there was like a blueness to
them and then when changji used them
there's the orangeness right you've
talked about this empty the like tallow
magic and the dark magic because i i
guess when when wu was using him was he
using like dark magic to utilize the
rings because he was doing evil things i
honestly do feel like you know just
based on like the the marvel trigger
theory video that i posted in the past i
think that the symbolism of wenwoo's
blue rings
sort of symbolizes that like his soul
was removed because i think that the
orange glow in all of the marvel movies
is symbolic of the soul stone and the
soul singularity magic so when shang chi
gets these rings he he hasn't had these
rings suck out his soul for a thousand
years right so like he's fresh so like
they're using the his power to to
activate whereas when woo doesn't have
like that orange soul glow in here
anymore because he used the rings the
reese probably sucked out all of his his
soul out his humanity's gone so he just
uses this dark energy around from around
him that he could just summon from the
air because dark energy is all around
well maybe that's really scientific well
and that's could be where the rings came
from right we don't know their origin
yeah they won't even tell us if they're
from earth or from space so they their
origins could be tied to dark magic i
mean they could be tied to the dark
empty i bet there's a page in the dark
hold about those rings that would be
honestly i think that's a huge
possibility because we're entering this
new chapter of darkness in the mcu
because we're getting the blade and
we're getting gore the god butcher when
i'm getting a multiverse of madness like
darkness is where this next phase of the
mcu is going for sure so like i can
definitely see these rings being tied to
a time from before the big bang even
happened so like that's why they're just
like we just this thing's super old we
can't even date it i would love to see
in the multiverse of madness like wong
maybe dr strange but maybe wong you know
he's like i got a guy hold on a second
he calls up shang chi me either strong
she comes and help or chunk she's like
here you can just use the rings for a
little bit and while wang maybe doesn't
know all the kung fu he just uses magic
to like use the rings right and have
them like float around him do some like
badass
magic geometric patterns with the rings
and then like yeah
would be so cool and then send them back
through the sling ring like there you go
thanks so much thanks for letting me
borrow this
really appreciate what we borrow
he just sends it back it's all bloody
covered in blood and guts of like
dimensional
the hell are the dudes
you gotta wash them wrong you gotta wash
the rings he's like that's not my job
anymore i'm so surprised
but hey let's discuss wong's weapon of
choice the wand of wood tomb because
first appearing in doctor strange this
weapon is used by magic wielders to help
enhance focus and redirect their magical
powers and wang uses it in the battle of
the hong kong sanctum at the end of
doctor 21. now what might be most
interesting about this weapon is that in
the comics there were actually six wands
spread across different dimensions and
the wand can be used to open portals to
other dimensions something that could be
useful in multiverse of madness so like
do you think that this could play a huge
role in the upcoming film i i really
hope so you know i think it dr strange
they they really introduced a lot of
they were not the comic book fans right
like you know here's here's the wand of
watum you know here's the crimson bands
of sidorak right and they just kind of
use them quickly in the movie and then
they disappear but these are supposed to
be like really important items right
doctor strange picks up that that vaz or
whatever it is it's like a cauldron or
something and you know kaiselius is like
do you even know how to use that and
he's like i know i have no idea uh but
it's like it's a very important thing in
the comics right so i i hope the wanda
wood tune comes back because like you
said that's a big big device in the
comics our boy zandu always going after
the wanda with two hey
the most powerful and feared villain
he's gonna be the secret building of
this whole thing man the phase four is
gonna be zandoo then do fans rise up
your time is now he's coming up all my
zen dudes out there stand up rising
dudes then dudes who do that let's go
come on zan dudes hit that subscribe
button come on let's get these likes to
10k baby but i i really i hope that
wonder what tomb comes back because it
is a really powerful device and like you
mentioned mt the fact that
you know in the comics is something
that's like spread across dimensions
that could be useful here right they're
gonna have to be opening dimensions and
breaking into other multiverses so i
would love to see the wand come back
here and really be utilized like really
channel some some powerful stuff and
become a big web for sure and like i
wonder if wong was using that in no way
home he's like you know what you guys do
your thing i'm going to use this
wonderful tomb to go to different
dimensions like what if that snowy place
was a different dimension yeah he was
packing his bags and taking the wander
with tomb on a trip around the dimension
yeah he's like i don't care what doctor
strange does as long as i have the most
important thing here the wonder wood
tube
it better show up again i would like to
see
i would like to see it come back in this
film
get utilized and maybe let doctor
strange use it maybe oh yeah no maybe
wong now is like i'm the source of
supreme now i don't need this
you can have it doctor strange this is
like training wheels yeah i don't need
these these are for lesser wisdom so you
can have it go ahead but hey one of the
most powerful weapons in the mcu right
now has got to be stormbreaker thor's
mighty axe of a replacement for his
beloved and crumbled mjolnir and but
still very much packs quite a punch and
this one doesn't have a very specific
enchantment that keeps anyone from
wielding it so you don't have to be
worthy to pick this bad boy up though
you probably need a significant arm
strength and the last we saw of storm
breaker thor was taking it with him for
his adventures with the asgardians of
the galaxy but if he were to get a call
from his good friend dr strange would he
be willing to lend it over to help could
dr strange even wield this thing with
his you know messed up hands he's just a
human being after all and he has messed
up fans so
what do you think i think he could do a
little magic enchantment to give him the
power to like pick up stormbreaker this
is this is probably a wild one i mean i
wouldn't expect to see this one
in the film but that would be so cool if
doctor strange was able to utilize it
again use a little magic have it like
swirl around your head send it shooting
into your villain you know aim for the
head you always gotta aim for the head
you always gotta aim for that dang head
man like come on like why would you not
we know in the comics that uh storm
breaker is primarily used by beta ray
bill so like what if we see a beta ray
bill variant or or an appearance in
multiverse of madness because we did see
him briefly appear as an easter egg in
uh thor ragnarok yeah that would be
awesome like i would love to see him
show up here
especially if we're going to be jumping
through multiverses and everything but
that would be a cool idea right it's not
the stormbreaker we see doctor strange
use isn't our thor's it's actually
banner right bills and he's like yeah go
ahead take this for a spin could i
borrow a couple of these
it's pretty neat go ahead i mean i
wouldn't let me use it in my universe so
like hey i'm sure it'd be cool if you
use it it doesn't matter i think it'd be
really dope if um if that stormbreaker
was an element i i would love to see
just a different thor we do know in the
comics that um donald blake was a big
part of you know of the four mythos
right and we haven't really seen this
donald blake separate from thor yet yeah
did you see that we do know that um
floor one briefly mentioned yeah they
teased it right we saw her she had the
the name tag that said donald blake or
whatever right yeah an old fling
this is my cane called stormbreaker just
a regular cave slash umbrella whatever i
need it to be really but hey speaking of
uh uh the uh canes and staffs and
whatnot uh
was odin's staff that we've seen wielded
in every thor film it's made of uru and
is able to project powerful amounts of
energy it can even channel dark energy
to act as a teleporter similar to the
bifrost and odin uses gangner to send
thor back to earth to retrieve the loki
in avengers which is why uh loki says
how much dark energy did your father
have to use to send you back oh dad
loves you so much
dad loves you more than me because he's
can also be used to operate the bifrost
just in case you you know misplace
heimdall's sword i lost it i know i can
see everything but i can't see where my
sword is
can see everything but can you see why
kids love the taste of cinnamon toast
crunch i don't think so but is this
staff really still around because during
the events of ragnarok we saw thor
utilize his father's weapon while bad
like his sister hela and he sort of
leaves it on the throne room as the
battle rages on and then searcher does
his thing and asgard is destroyed so can
we assume that this staff is just
floating around in space somewhere like
could dr strange just snag it and use it
like is do you think it's still intact
yes and yes
uh there's no way the staff got
destroyed when ragnarok happened it's
too powerful it's such an important item
i think it is just kind of floating
around in space you know there was lots
of stuff in odin's vault that i you know
i assume is just still floating in space
like the cask of ancient winters right
there's no way that thing was destroyed
uh it's too powerful i think it's just
like debris floating out there so if you
know how to fly to asgard you can just
go grab it right uh but i think dr
strange could like open a little portal
and like zoop zip it right out of space
because he can sense it as guardian
magic i think is probably pretty close
to eldritch magic i i would assume those
two things are
very similar you know they're both
tied to earth in similar ways they're
utilized on earth and in different
places throughout the universe uh so i
would think that if any of these items
would respond to magic that doctor
strange uses it would be like an
asgardian item he could he could utilize
this
and it would be really cool to see that
come back loki killed his dad with it
right then he stabbed lauffy with with
his dad's spear or his yeah
he incinerated him yeah yeah oh yeah he
like gave him a flame yeah he's no more
uh that was pretty pretty diesel if we
don't see it in in this next film it
it's gotta show back up in thor four
right it should be what valkyrie has
she's the boss now she's she's the king
of asgard oh yeah give her the give her
gun meal let her use it dung gungner can
also like channel like uh the odin force
right it can direct that magic through
it so it it is a powerful item and of
anything i think like this one could
come back for sure
uh and it would be cool to see it get
used in not a thor film like have it
show up in doctor strange it'd be super
dope if it showed up a doctor straight
to multiverse madness because like like
you said it's like probably one of the
most powerful weapons if not the most
powerful weapon
i mean i don't want to say that hot tape
i mean i i mean obviously there's the
infinity gauntlet so like that's yeah
that's old school we're done with that
let's move on yeah yeah it's just a
glove who cares but i am seeing our
infinity stones have been atomized or
have they they haven't it was a trick
i would love to see
gungner factor into armor wars in some
way even it would be crazy if it was
just like you know we literally have
armor like this is like a weapon um
people showing up and all these like you
know we tony stark like you know iron
man type suits and someone just like
collecting them on the staff just
stabbing right through them making shish
kebabs out of these bad boys just like
rhodiums and dogs like big stuff like oh
no
yeah hell yeah it's a stick but here's
one you may not have considered a temp
pad and these are the devices introduced
in the loki series that allow the tva to
move through time and space utilizing
time doors and they can also be used to
call miss minutes my former uh wife who
turned out to be evil but you know
marriage most wives do
and they could also be used to call miss
minich which depending on what mood
she's in could be a good or bad thing a
temper will be extremely useful if
steven needed to jump around the
timeline and we saw in one of the doctor
strange trailers what could possibly be
a orange glow of a time door so it's
possible a temp pad could make an
appearance in multiverse of madness but
how do these things work now that the
tva has been retconned by the death of
he who remains like do you think they
still like function the same or the
changes that were made to the tva were
pretty superficial right the statue
changed people don't know people the
same way anymore but like most of the
infrastructure is still there so i would
imagine that these temp heads would
still work i mean this is a really cool
idea mt that like doctor strange use a
tin pad here to like jump around in time
to get through it i mean those things do
need to be recharged remember like
sylvie's battery when she was using it
the battery was running low it must be
connected to some sort of main you know
tva computer so someone could probably
track you if you were using it that's
how they caught you know sylvia and
stuff dad there's like [ __ ] here and
stuff sweetheart how many times have i
told you don't say and stuff just say
dad there are [ __ ] here well there's
like a ton this would be a really cool
idea you know we talk about all these
weapons and powerful items but this item
is super powerful for what it's where
it's able to move you around time and
space so i think definitely this would
be a really cool thing for doctor
strange to use i would assume he'd be
able to figure out how to use it he's a
pretty smart guy
uh he reads a lot
it seems pretty user friendly
and man if miss minutes shows up in
multiverse of madness all bets are off
baby i don't know if i can handle that
it's been a rough divorce
um but you know
i think i i'll be able to
work my way up to us being in the same
room together one of these days but uh
it's i don't know if it's gonna be today
one of these days i honestly think that
there could be a link between
these tva doors and dr strange's magic
like 100 honestly because like they both
are orange energy sources and i and we
do know that doctor strange's magic
allows for teleportation across
distances right there could be a
possibility that you know whatever power
source uh powers these tva uh temp ads
could be linked to whatever energy that
the wizards of commerce use like i think
that doctor strange could be a very
proficient at a temp door and could
theoretically maybe even create one
himself um but who knows i mean how
pissed is he gonna be if he gets a tim
pad and it's like you could just use one
of these to jump around time i'm messing
with a time stone like i'm breaking the
fabric of the universe and you guys are
just using a little uh a calculator to
get around so like this isn't fair he's
gonna be right he's so pissed like i
could have used one of these on the top
of mount everest a couple movies ago
i almost died
rude but those are our top picks for our
top powerful artifacts in the mcu still
around today what do you think might
make it appearance brandon uh i mean out
of all of these what's like these are a
lot of cool things you know we know the
mcu they love to throw in new stuff all
the time we're probably gonna get some
new stuff you know like in uh no way
home they throw in the machina cadavers
out of nowhere and then it's gone again
so we'll probably get new stuff but if
there's gonna be a return of an artifact
you've made a lot of strong arguments
here today i'm gonna put my money on the
ten rings i would love to see them show
up just a little appearance again you
know they're new they're hot on the
scene uh i'd like to see him again in
this movie just real quick a little pop
in pop out of the ten rings would be
really awesome what about you emt we
know that the doctoral is gonna be in
this so i'm not gonna say the dark hold
because that's obviously the most
important um but yeah i think the ten
rings are going to play a huge role uh
moving forward because like i i believe
personally that they are tied to this
new dark chapter of the mcu and they are
like a dark um item much like your your
ebony blade that we saw at the end of
eternals i think we're just going to get
all these dark items and i would love to
see the 10 rings
further explained um
by having like either a variant pop up
and just be like all right here this hen
rings wong had an analysis let's see
what dr strange thinks of these ten
rings yeah so yeah i think it'd be
really dope to see uh the ten rings just
factor in and maybe a one move variant
popped up and uh just mess things up i
would love to see one on the council are
you kidding oh yeah on the illuminati
council like a one word that doesn't get
beat by shanxi and keeps them for
another thousand years and gets even
more evil and dark and messed up yeah
that would be really cool before we
continue our friends at epicura shop
have three new batman inspired shirts
just in time for the film's premiere and
you won't find these original designs
anywhere else and they also have
multiple sock designs and even a riddler
tie so find all this cool new merch and
lots more over at new rockstarsmerch.com
and before we dive into our bite size
questions next some words from the
lovely people that help bring us big
question to you people like avast cyber
security is confusing and scary but
luckily we have avast to help us with it
avast has been a global leader in cyber
security for more than 30 years and is
trusted by over
435 million users and thanks to avas for
supporting bigquestion avast empowers
you with digital safety and privacy no
matter who you are where you are or how
you connect so you can enjoy the
opportunities that come with being
connected on your turns a vast new
all-in-one solution a vast one helps you
take control of your safety and privacy
online through a range of features learn
more about avast one at avast.com a vast
antivirus stops viruses and malware from
harming your devices in avast pc speedup
manages the background data apps use and
speeds up your pc i like the peace of
mind you get from a vast one from not
having to worry about viruses or malware
and avast prevents over 1.5 billion
attacks every month and with a vast one
you can confidently take control of your
online world without worrying about
viruses phishing attacks ransomware
hacking attempts and other cyber crimes
that should not be allowed learn more
about avast one at avast.com
online shopping isn't slowing down
anytime soon i know you wanted to but
it's not going to is your business ready
to keep up with the pace with
shipstation you'll never worry about
shipping again imagine a world where
you're never worrying about shipping the
things you could do the things you could
worry about it'll be great make the
switch to handle all your shipping needs
quickly affordably and painlessly go to
ship station ship station is already
trusted by over a hundred thousand
e-commerce sellers keep track of orders
from any sales channel easily find the
best shipping carrier with deeply
discounted rates automate just about any
shipping task with just a few clicks
we've used shipstation at new rockstars
and loved how easy it made shipping a
bunch of stuff to a bunch of different
people it was also great to save money
by comparing the rates of different
carriers save time by funneling all your
orders into one simple interface no
matter what you're selling manage every
order amazon ebay etsy or your own
website from anywhere even your phone
make shipping the easy part of having an
online store no wonder 98 of companies
that use shipstation for a year keep
using it for as long as they're in
business it's that good ship more in
less time with shipstation use code big
question to get a 60-day free trial
that's two months free of no hassle
stress-free shipping just go to
shipstation.com click on the microphone
at the top of the page and type in big
question ship station make ship happen
ooh you said a bad word
you said ship it's tricky
and hey we love to learn more about our
audience and what you're into so we can
make creative choices and choose
sponsors that are relevant to our fans
because i just feel like that makes
sense so there's a quick survey that
we'd really appreciate if you could take
at the bottom of the description box
below so check out the link in the
description to give us some feedback
because we would really appreciate it so
you could see more things that you guys
would like to see as sponsors because we
just don't want to you know just shove
random things into your eyeballs we love
doing these ad reads right but we want
to do ad reads for ads that you want to
hear read to you you know what's super
kind brandon what food especially
bite-sized food
it's time for a bite-sized question
brandon
that's how i eat i say
every time i eat must be so great on
dates with empty here
it's why i'm single
she's like
i'm gonna leave bye
i'm going
home brendan what is the better overall
metal baskar or vibranium this is from
cameron metal struggles on discord thank
you cameron oh boy here we go we're
comparing metallic elements from two
completely different fictional universes
so let's just lay that caveat right out
at the top okay this is nearly
impossible to do but we're gonna do it
all right best guard the metal so loved
by the mandalorians in the star wars
universe and vibranium the compound from
the meteorite that landed in wakanda and
is used to make all sorts of amazing
tech most notably cap shield and black
panther's suit okay so these are our two
metals we're going to compare we'll
start with best scar from the star wars
universe okay it has a high tolerance to
different forms of damage whether it's
like physical
blaster fire heat
very high tolerance to that very hard to
damage uh it could even repel lightsaber
strikes i mean that's pretty badass
right lightsabers are that is superb
yeah it's a very powerful weapon in the
star wars universe and this is like the
one metal that can resist it it's the
toughest and most legendary metal in the
galaxy for star wars so
that's
it's very important very very high
functioning stuff and here's a fun fact
for you folks at home the term best car
didn't come around until an article from
the star wars insider magazine in 2006
uh this article was called the
mandalorians poland people and culture
before then this medal was just called
mandalorian iron uh
and it only comes from mandalore and its
moon concordia so that's why it's so
valuable and so precious but yeah bescar
is a very fresh term i don't even know
this it's super fresh from 2006. then we
have vibranium and guess what folks it's
also incredibly strong and durable
that's what i keep hearing vibranium can
absorb vibration right and it can also
deflect kinetic energy so you know when
we see like bullets hit vibranium they
bounce off and they don't just like drop
down they can bounce off and hurt other
people i think captain america has used
that quite effectively with his shield
and vibranium can also conduct
electricity which is good and bad good
because you know you can use it as a
conductive element but also bad because
black widow was able to just like shock
uh black panther he was like
you know
it's tough that's tough sometimes and of
course vibranium comes from somewhere in
the universe we don't really know where
it comes from necessarily
presumably there's a whole planet that
comes from florida oh from florida great
yeah
all the good things that come from
florida right oranges and vibranium
that's it there's a limited supply on
earth though not that limited we saw
those caverns in black panther and
they're still mining it out of the
ground so they seem to have a lot of
they they barely scratch the surface
there yeah best car they're they're
trying to collect what's left the best
car because you know mandalore got blown
up in theory there's a ton of vibranium
throughout the galaxy of
the mcu um but
finding it can be tough another
important thing that both of these
elements share is they can damage
themselves right so best car can damage
baskar vibranium damages vibranium you
know we've seen this played out in both
both franchises uh they're both great
metals but at the end of the day
i think vibranium slightly takes the
lead over best car mainly because it's
more malleable you know what i mean we
saw like best scar made into that cute
little chainmail for for a little grogu
right and that's pretty flexible you
make the little links but vibranium they
weave into their clothing as claw said
right like they you can make vibranium
into this very light thin mesh so i
think it's just it has a slightly more
advantage because it's a little more
malleable uh than bhaskar is but these
are both great metals guys i don't want
to have a big fight about it but in my
humble opinion i think vibranium is a
slightly better metal than vessel but
our second bite size question of the day
is how fast can iron man fly this is
from
iajsmith24 on discord once again i aj
smith we love you thank you for your
questions yes thank you thank you so how
fast can an iron man fly well in the
comics iron man has been shown to be
able to reach some phenomenal speeds he
was able to escape a black hole which
means he would need to travel about the
speed of light pretty fast if you're not
familiar with it uh a little fast yeah
in the comics when he joined the
guardians of the galaxy he created a
special armor that allowed him to travel
at warp speeds between planets and
subwarp speed when he was just kind of
you know cruising around which was about
mach 10 a roughly uh you know seven
thousand four hundred miles per hour so
pretty fast pretty fast just a casual
mock yeah just like casual mach 10. and
even you know in the first avengers he
chases down a missile which is probably
going about mach 5. so he's going pretty
quick uh but most importantly we saw in
infinity war how he used that little
extra boost to chase down ebony ma in
his flying donut right he had he had to
catch that spaceship that was leaving
earth's atmosphere and to leave earth's
orbit you need to be going at least at
least 25 000 miles per hour uh and tony
was able to catch up to the ship which
was probably going at least that speed
so
if he puts on that extra juice we know
he can at least get up to 25 000 miles
per hour so that's pretty fast pretty
fast uh it's a good thing you can pee in
the suit because i would be peeing my
pants if i was going that fast
uh in an iron man suit for sure i hope
you could poop in the suit because
that's what i need
yeah turn into energy yeah i'd be like
jarvis get me the brown suit here we go
let's go maybe that's why he can go uh
mach 10 is because the poop is helping
him project forward like super mario
sunshine that's disgusting i am so sorry
here we go um but now it is time for my
favorite part of the show way less dark
than that the box of scratches oh the
box of scraps
with my subscribes brandon yeah if you
could have any one artifact from any
fictional universe other than a box of
scraps from iron man 1 and be able to
use it what would it be and why
item from any fictional universe i'm
going to turn uh to an animated universe
here
i'm i'm gonna take the old uh
the lamp
from aladdin the genie's lamp oh that's
a good one oh my i've always wanted one
ever since i watched aladdin i was
obsessed with goldie going look at my
three wishes you know what i mean i
think i think that's what i'm going to
do
what would you wish for you can't say
what i wish for out loud uh it won't
come true right i guess you have to say
it out loud to the lamp right
he's like do sign language please don't
say it out loud the first wish is going
to be tons of crypto
crypto baby
honestly just having genie as a friend
um you know it's just a really great
idea you never had a friend like him you
know that's what i hear but for me um
it's definitely not as i feel as cool or
efficient i feel as a as having a genie
but i do think that having a tardis from
doctor who would be freaking awesome i'm
a huge doctor who nerd it's my favorite
tv show of all time do this day that's
pretty good um so i would love to have a
time traveling police box where i could
just travel to space and time and uh
just neglect my responsibilities because
why not now i'm like i'm not up on
doctor who i'm not a doctor who
aficionado don't come at me don't at me
okay i don't have the time obviously
you're normal what's the little what's
your magic wand that uh that
he has the sonic screwdriver the size of
the screwdriver that he just it helps
advance the plot
all right here we go
you know that would be helpful in my
life too something that advances the
plot of my life a little bit would be
very helpful
exactly you know i'm not about my doctor
who but i always say to all my doctor
who friends i wish you the best with
doctor who
every time there's a new a new series
coming out i'm like i hope it's great
for you guys i hope it gives you
everything you want because i think i
think the doctor who fans they get the
high highs but man they get the low lows
and i feel bad you'll be getting the low
lows man it's been rough on these
streets over the past couple of years
man but russell t davis he's coming back
i'm always i'm always showing for my
doctor who fans out there i want i want
the best for you guys you guys
you've earned it you deserve it best
doctor whoever it's coming your way i
promise i promise but that is it for
this episode of big question a huge
thank you to brandon as always for
joining me on this episode follow him at
grin and barrack if you want to see him
tweet amazing things follow me
mastertainment if you want to see
between some really weird things but
follow new rockstars anywhere we are on
social media especially on youtube and
when you do on youtube make sure you hit
that notification bell so you get
notifications every time we upload a
video which is basically every day and
if you want to continue the conversation
join our new rockstars discord if you
are 18 years old and older but yeah
thank you guys so much for watching this
video we love you guys so much and thank
you so much for spending time with us we
cannot wait to talk to you guys again
goodbye bye bye
see you later
kiss my ass
so when when when the wind chunks
do you know anyone who'd want to put a
banana in your husband's rectum
in the comics stormbreaker is the hammer
of
a
billy wright cyrus what was i gonna say
billy ray cyrus someone kill me i can't
die wow
existence is pain roger roger
hold on
get him the rings he's dying
what are you listening to john you can
hear that yes i can hear that someone's
at the doctor's office
i can still hear it
that's an app josh
randall can see everything but can you
see why kids love the taste of cinnamon
toast crunch i don't think so
yeah i still hear it
[Music]
always grab the hurty gir the hurdy
gurdy
people showing up in all these like tony
stark like you know iron man type suits
and someone just like collecting them on
the staff just stabbing right through
them making shish kebabs out of these
bad boys it's just like roni has to die
like biggest down like oh now
that you rocked the scars there so
chicks didn't rock that
so
sorry
after the
hadith singing songs
i'd like to see like you know when he
first gets the rings like how many
different ways can i use this i would
put this on my foot don't don't think
too hard about that question you're
gonna get a pretty crotchy
that's how i eat i say hemne every time
i eat must be so great on dates with
empty here
in the restaurant after the first
the girl just quickly exits
[Laughter]
and you won't find these originals
i keep going every time i speed up i
trip up my words i just get so anxious
because i'm like editors need to get
this done fast i'm so sorry
yeah smash it back in man keep track of
orders from any sales channel easily
find the best shipping
[Music]
you